[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
how are you today i hope you're uh doing
well ryan are you all right i'm doing
okay yeah doing okay i'm a little under
the weather today yeah
you've assured me it's not coveted so
we're okay i got tested yesterday for
cove and i wasn't covered but uh just
like a head cold or a sinus thing
something going on i got a tailor to
tellable i got a terrible allergy attack
uh because the weather changed
drastically wasn't that the worst i
just want nothing worse than feeling
like [ __ ] just feeling off oh my god
it's all on your face i mean i had to
interview someone today
but that went fine i went well but i was
uh you know at some points i was just
like oh my god
but uh he survived got a great guest
today we'll get into that in just a
minute but i want to thank everybody for
uh coming to the shows
the stage it shows again i want to say
you know uh
on march 5th we had two shows and we did
really well a lot of people showed up
and uh thank you for supporting my band
sunspin
and uh
also if you want to follow the podcast
it means a lot if uh
thank you by the way for spending your
afternoon with us or just an hour with
us a week it's not asking much but there
are a lot of choices and you choose to
be here and i really appreciate that so
thank you uh what are the handles for
our podcast ryan oh they're out inside
if you call it on twitter inside of you
podcast on instagram and facebook that's
absolutely right and uh there's also an
inside of you online store if you want
to go to that just go to the inside of
your online store we got great stuff
like smallville signed lunch boxes
from tom and myself uh inside of you
mugs tumblers
all a bunch of stuff just go look at
there's a lot of great stuff on there
also a big shout out to all my patrons
uh they give the uh give back to the
podcast in many ways and if you go to
patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com slash inside of you you can join
the wonderful family there's different
tiers and things you get from me and
youtube lives and all this stuff and i
will uh as soon as you join i will send
you a message
thanking you
inside of you it's called it's
patreon.com
inside of you
and uh i appreciate you listening i
appreciate you writing a review if you
like the show uh today's guest is uh you
know i didn't really know much about him
i didn't know much about josh peck
and uh he's got a big following
you know he talks about being a child
actor and how how he had to grow out of
that
and uh
just you know being on drugs and he was
very open and honest he has a new book
out and i really enjoyed having him on
wasn't he wasn't he fun he was good he
was and i think you're gonna really
enjoy this one so let's get inside
of josh peck it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience i know ryan do you yeah do ryan
reynolds
no i'm not that fancy ryan philippi
i had i saw him at a fancy la eatery
once felipe and the worst
the worst part was my mom got there
first
so i walk in and i see her talking to
ryan philippe he's with his beautiful
children right and my mom as i walk in
goes
you know my son he's famous too
and i'm like oh god mom your mom did
that it's the worst central ever oh man
is your mom jewish
i think that's safe to say i'm a jew so
that my mom my mom would do that [ __ ]
my grandmother would do that [ __ ] she
feels the urge to
anywhere we are
and it's been years i mean like the the
people she's talking to probably don't
know smallville you know or whatever or
some things that i've done and she'll go
into a restaurant and the waitress will
come over a server you can't say
waitress anymore i don't know what the
[ __ ] he could say anymore i can't say
anything i i just shut my mouth because
i just say the wrong thing all the time
same yeah inadvertently but you know the
server will come and go oh can i get you
some menu she's like yeah my son's
famous my grandson he's famous
she's like
great
and it's not for you like it could be
confused is like pride it's not it's all
self-serving for them it is isn't it
yeah
it's for them it's for them to feel good
it's my mom knows it makes me viscerally
at my deepest level uncomfortable you
say anything to her
every time almost every time big fights
over it really yeah
like literally especially when it's when
i'm having rough times and she's like
pitching me like i've got a new show
coming out i'm like i haven't worked in
19 months i haven't had a call back in
11 months
not looking good for me might have to go
you know find a real job
and she's like no no you got the magic
and people know
i'm like ma don't do this when i'm
around you i feel bad about me so
when i'm around you i feel bad about me
is that in your book should be it should
be yeah i like that i mean you've got a
story man i you know what what i like is
that you see where you come from
and you know obviously drake and josh
and and how i met your fathers on hulu
now and social influencer and all these
movies turner and hooch and red dawn and
like
you've done so many things and then you
write a book it's like it's never enough
josh is now he has to be an author
yes and and it's author of happy people
are annoying
which is a great title thank you that's
a really great title because happy
people are annoying
yeah how are they annoying to you
well i just i always think the first
thing when i think that i think of when
i'm out and i'm you know i'm single i'm
lonely and then you see a couple and
they're laughing and giggling and i'm
like oh [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them but that's not right because
why should you be like that way about
other people you want the other people
to be happy but it says something about
yourself in a lot of ways doesn't it oh
yeah someone said to me the other day
he's like i don't like forced fun which
is why i don't go to coachella
anyone's who's capable of force fun like
we're like we're gonna go
to the new harry potter thing at
universal studios and i'm like
unironically and they're like yeah
butterbeer i'm like i don't get you
butter they're hyped i don't understand
you or do you think i mean look we'll
get into it but overall do you think
because i could answer this
are you a happy person do you feel like
you are happy you've gone through a lot
in your life but overall when you wake
up and you look in the mirror and you're
by yourself and there's nobody around
you
can you honestly look at yourself in the
mirror and look at your reflection go
i like you i love you i'm happy
i think so i mean the conceit of the
book is like where i started it was
throughout most of my life i'd look at
people who were inherently happy or at
least exuding what looked like happiness
and i thought oh like happiness is
reserved for quarterbacks and
cheerleaders and like people who have
like inherited money and people with six
packs and like all these things and i
figured that everyone had been handed a
manual for life at birth that i was just
not privy to like i didn't get that
right
so i was resentful at i was like no it's
i you know things affect me too deeply
i'm too sensitive too analytical too
neurotic for this world right so i would
look at these people and just be like oh
you don't get it like you're you're
humming at this weird level that i'll
never be at but like where i'm at
feeling the feelings this is life this
is real exactly that's there's something
truthful about that i mean
i think you know i i was a short kid i
was the shortest kid in my high school i
didn't start puberty too late i was you
know i was picked on i was not popular
and um going through high school i would
just look around me and go god i wish i
was that guy it was all envy it was like
i wish i was that guy which is the
quarterback i wish i had that girl i
wish i could get that if that girl just
gave me the chance you'd see how funny
and sweet i was but i'll never get that
chance
they're happy i want to be like them yes
that's always the feeling but
i don't believe that anybody's truly
happy i think we're all trying to like
you said something about being content
what is it you said about being content
it was a quote or something in your book
about being content and that's that's
with yourself just saying i am good
enough it's like that that saturday
night live thing what was uh i'm good
enough i'm smart enough and god damn it
what does he say yeah yeah yeah you know
people like that and people like me yes
but you know it's sort of like hey this
is me this is what i've got and there's
these personal traits these personal
things that these
these things that we do
that we just try to escape like this
makes i'm annoyed at myself
i i don't think
you know
i'm like why would anybody want to be my
friend why would anybody want to talk to
me why would anybody want to you know
and you start to think that that's who
you are
and you try to escape it you try to push
it away yes i'll have a cooler
personality i'll be cooler i'll be quiet
i'll be this but your real self comes
out
it just comes out right
yeah i mean to your point like that it
took me so long long to learn the
duality of ego and being self-centered
and i used to think much like
quarterbacks like
if you're self-centered or you're
egotistical like that's reserved for
high achievers um and then someone would
show me like hey if you spend all day
thinking about how great you are or how
awful you are
you're only thinking about you you're
self-centered wow and i was like oh
that too
i'm also self-centered oh good but it's
true like i think like the ego and and i
can only speak for myself but my mind
wants me separate from like it doesn't
want me to be a worker amongst workers
it either wants me to be like i'm
somehow pleased with a performance of
mine and i'm like well this
verifies my suspicion that i'm the best
i'm the [ __ ] man
or 90 of the time i'll see something i
dislike or
anything you know anything can trigger
it something doesn't work out and i go i
knew it this is but a preview of more
bad to come yeah you know yeah and my
mind just wants me all alone instead of
being like yeah highs and lows that's
life you know me and the next guy how
hard are you on yourself do you think
you've let up a little bit do you think
you over the years you've just become
more like hey i'm going to be better to
myself i'm because i think that's really
important to just
be good to yourself to give yourself a
break to say i'm not perfect to say i'm
not
i'm not all these things but i am all
these things and you know do you are you
hard on yourself i am but i
to your point yeah like i'm 35 you're 35
yeah you look young thanks man i thought
maybe you were like 26.
ryan what did you think no i i read this
i read the wikipedia no i knew him my
man ryan and his reasons
for trying over here but also he walked
in and i looked you in the face like oh
that's someone around my age because
that rarely happens in here so are you
are you i'm 33 but i'm about to turn 34.
and you look great too right thanks man
you got grades we both have dark hair i
got a lot of grays yeah it's not just
dark hair no i mean they're coming in i
gotta cut my head and then see right now
i'm looking at both of you and listening
to both you and thinking [ __ ] off
because i'm going to be 50 in a few
months and you have no gray hairs though
i have gray hairs right here that's it
right now on top and a great i mean
great head of lettuce over there so far
they can't why you get gray hairs you're
oh yeah you do oh they're you dye it no
they're here i just they i kind of put
some gel in so it helps like chill i get
what should i say pomade pomade sure i
you know i just was wondering what you
used cream that was like
whatever has been sent to me for free
like i feel like the one thing you get
is an actor of any sort of like you
could either be an oscar winner or you
know on infomercials you can probably
get free hair products yeah that's true
i'll get you know a couple things of gel
a year and be like well once these are
done i guess i'll go and buy some at
rite aid what's the coolest free [ __ ]
you've gotten
oh i got a car for a couple months they
let me borrow a car was this the gm was
there oh gm's doing it well they did i
remember i had some friends that got
three cars for a while and i never was
that guy i never got that i might when
my wife was pregnant i made because i
was doing a lot of social media and
youtube stuff so i made this video where
i told my friends like where i would
tell them that she was pregnant and
catch their reactions and it's just like
this feel good thing
and it was beautiful because a lot of
people saw it and a lot of baby brands
were like need a stroller and i was like
in fact i do
strollers are expensive as hell so i got
the stroller and a few other things
and acura randomly emailed and was like
need a car for the first couple months
with your new kiddo and i was like who
am i to turn down acura parent company
of honda man acura gave him a free car
but then hard body karate i hope you're
listening acura they like hit us up
randomly like somewhere two and a half
months in and was like we're taking it
back tomorrow i'm like no planning no
heads up back here because we want it
back yeah we're over you you didn't post
enough is that what it was probably oh
my god yeah that's the thing hey do me a
favor take me back to
take me back to childhood take me back
to when you were a kid
because
you know i used to complain everybody
complains about their parents and it's
just like you know my dad's this he's
not affectionate he doesn't say i love
you he doesn't he's not you know he's
not really present
my mom's this she's off the wall she's
just everybody complains and everybody's
got it some people have it worse and
people there's always people out there
that have it worse
i look at your life and i'm like
your father wasn't there
right and your mother raised you
and that had to be hard as [ __ ] for a
little kid
yes can i say [ __ ] on the podcast can
you can i run ryan it's your old podcast
sure yeah i say so thanks yeah why not
yeah but you know just i look at that
i'm like right away i'm like wow i'm
sort of like i feel for you
like you didn't have that father figure
and talk to me about that how was that
pretty tough
i you know i didn't know i didn't miss
what i had never had so
i talk about this in my book and it's
it's much like we were we were talking
about like
my biggest issue with life and god in
the universe was just how different i
was like i didn't have a dad i was fat
like i was a musical theater kid i
wasn't good at sports
single mom like we were just
we were so terminally unique at a time
where
you don't want like you just desperately
want to fit in even like you know
there's no there's not really jew heroes
when you're eight like there was like
sandy koufax within three four of my
time you're like yeah i know we got
einstein but it's not really
is there a jew pokemon that's amazing
yeah
i need a hero and so
i
that's amazing
so yeah i but i didn't have a resentment
against my dad i had a resentment of
against god like i even talk about how
my mom and i
she has a fear of flying so we would
constantly take trains or drive you know
from new york to florida and i'm like of
course because flying would be too
normal for the backs
and
yeah and and then the dad stuff started
to sort of rear its ugly head in my
teens and when i was able to finally
sort of face it or start cracking that
anger and resentment that i had was
actually when i started losing weight
and it was until i was in my 20s and i
found out that he had passed away and i
had this wave of
just sort of i don't know if it was
remorse or regret in having never
meeting him that i was like wait i i now
have to mourn this guy i never met too
so there were many phases to working it
out there's there's a weird
i guess innate sadness about that like
sort of you know
[ __ ] him he wasn't here mom's taking
care of me i've got it i have a career
i'm making money i'm living my life
and then the guy that never was there
dies
and it still affects you yes how do i
mean what do you do how do you deal with
that
you know for the years
leading up to that i was again in my
early 20s i'd gotten sober and i lost
all this weight and i was like
my career was so up and down but like i
knew there was enough data to support
that
i think things are going to work out in
some way i have no idea how but i i've
sort of made it i'm certainly the weight
and height of a full-grown man and i
think i might be on my way there right
and i was like if i go find my dad right
now he's 86
and i'm 24 or 25 at the time and i don't
need anything from him so what do i get
like he gets this great kid who doesn't
need anything
and i don't get the full dad experience
like i get this geriatric dude and i was
yeah
and then when i found out he had passed
away and i tell the story in the book
he had no online footprint because the
dude was almost 90.
and so your mom liked older dudes yeah
well my mom's older she's older my mom
was 43 when she had me and he was like
62. wow she did like the older guys
shout out mom i seen the book like my
dad was getting like medicare and chicks
pregnant
that's that's nice that's nice respect
right
um
but i
you know i i i decided i knew that he
had another family and
my mom had met his other family like his
wife who he
supposedly was had a well-timed
separation on the one night that he
actually hooked up with my mom
and like his kids who were grown because
he was an older guy so a bunny of mine
said why don't we search your your
siblings you know their name
and all of a sudden on facebook like i
had never i'm 26 i'd never even seen a
picture of him and suddenly you know
what he looked like
i mean i assumed he looked like a
jewishy richard gere
that's what you were thinking in your
head oh it's like this is what this dad
looks like right at best oh you're right
not bad not a bad looking guy pretty
good looking guy nice yeah it's
certainly nice i'll show you a picture
of him i carried him on my phone you do
like because people wonder they're like
oh what you know they
i always say like their your parents are
like these weird genetic road maps and
all i had was my mom so
it felt like half of me i wasn't
informed on what to expect right but
but anyway i i find my siblings and
there's all these posts throughout their
life of them with their father and
at bar mitzvahs and weddings and then
inevitably when he passed away these
beautiful tributes to him and i just
kind of said you know majority rules
like
this guy had a family
and it would have taken a shitload of
courage to be able to tell them what had
happened
and
they didn't know what happened i'm
assuming not i'm not exactly hiding
but i don't yeah i don't think so
otherwise i imagine my siblings might be
like wait we have like a brother out
there who's famous he doesn't suck who
doesn't suck yeah yeah
so yeah it weirdly allowed me to forgive
him in a weird way i was like oh you
weren't like there's more than one part
of you and what i needed you to be for
me you were you were for this other
family and i can't be the arbiter of
like the ultimate right or the ultimate
good yeah but
and then of course uh you know because
you're a dad right
to a dog
exactly you get it i get it right yes
human and dog very similar soon so the
the the argument could be made that the
dog is superior but it was until i had
my own kid and i had to do it with him
and i was like oh like my dad missed all
this and so he didn't get off scot-free
he just
messed up yeah
did you was there a party that i want
him to see my fame i wanted to see that
i did all right i want to see him to see
that i made money and then i'm i'm on my
two feet and i could do this and i don't
need him
i
maybe i mean i my mom
had sent him a picture of me when i was
five and just sort of like um a quick
little blurb about where i was at and
crushing you know blocks or reading and
rushing blocks did he respond he no and
so i was like oh he turned down this
like fetching five-year-old like so i
just figured he was probably so
i people always say like you think he
thought about you on like
his last
couple hours on this earth and i was
like i hope not
i hope not i would have been inside
would be like i hope he did i hope he
thought of me i hope he thought about
the one thing that he regretted the one
thing that he just wish he would have
done differently and that was me
yeah you know i get i think that a lot
of people would think that way
yeah it seems like you got your [ __ ]
together and you're a little more humble
than that maybe it took a lot of work
again i'm so damn self-centered that
it's almost like i can't even think
about the reasons why
you know i am the way i am or i have the
insecurities or trauma or dysfunction i
just i'm so so like i blame myself for
everything for better or for worse
really pretty much yeah but i spin out
when i do that and and then i just go
and then i just get a case of the [ __ ]
it so i have to mitigate that two tears
in a bucket [ __ ] yeah
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
online therapy
everybody knows these guys
everybody loves them i love them ryan
that's great yeah yep it's helping you
getting a lot out of it ain't men look
folks relationships take work especially
the most important one you can have in
your life and that is your relationship
with yourself a lot of us will drop
anything to go help someone we care
about we'll go out of our way to treat
other people well but how often do we
give ourselves the same treatment
it's true we don't we're not good to
ourselves enough and you got to be good
to yourself and you'll learn how to be
good yourself but one of those things
you could do is join
better help this month better help
online therapy wants to remind you that
you matter just as much as everyone else
does and therapy is a great way to make
sure you show up for yourself ryan what
would you say better help is doing for
you
uh it is helping me to
learn about myself better uh how to
treat myself better uh
and just talking about things that are
bothering me however big or small yeah
because sometimes you think oh i have
friends to talk to you i have
no you you can't be
absolutely open with your thoughts and
your demons and your thing just with
friends or you know people think they
take it it's so
easy you know like oh i don't need to
worry about that and it builds up and it
builds up and it festers and
we all implode at some point
so we got to take care of ourselves and
better help online therapy is there to
help us better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and inside of you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash
inside thank you better help
couldn't do it without you inside of you
is brought to you by ferrari
ferrari brand is unbelievable and let me
tell you why this is the company that i
actually went out
to get
i had probably bought
five or six shirts
and other articles of clothing
and i just love how they feel
the softness and the quality of the
product and i and i asked my my lovely
agnes who's uh who works over at
westwood one i said can you get verity
on i just love ferrity
and guess what we got faraday
everyone's talking about fake spring and
how difficult it is to dress around this
time but that's because it is
it can be so difficult to find the right
outfit in the spring when every day is
different and weather can change at the
drop of a hat
luckily
therapy makes it way easier they make
the perfect clothes for all seasons and
that is the truth faraday is a
family-run brand making high-quality
timeless clothing with modern design and
functionality it's that kind of
effortless style you want every time you
go digging into your closet that set
that shirt that dress that feels like
you have had them for years maybe it's
in a gorgeous print and it looks like it
might be vintage but it fits so well
that it feels like it was made just
yesterday just for you well that's
parody yeah i love this and i love how
i'm not one to always say hey touch me
but i'm always like to my friends i'm
like hey feel this feel you got to feel
this quality kind of like a little
stretch warmth comfort you have to try
fahrity you really do i want them to
stick around to sponsors for one but
really i love their their product and i
hope you guys do verity is so confident
the quality of their stuff they have a
lifetime guarantee of quality they will
replace
or fix your clothes
forever
no matter what have you ever heard of
that with clothes talk about making it
easier to get dressed and right now
faraday is giving all my listeners
inside of you listeners
20 off
20 percent off
head to ferrity that's
f-a-h-e-r-t-y brand b-r-a-n-d
faradybrand.com
and use code inside of you at checkout
to snag 20 off all your new spring
staples that's inside of you at
faraday
f-a-h-e-r-t-y brand
dot-com for 20 off
you were doing stand-up at like eight
years old is that true i was how is that
possible where are you doing this i was
too fat for t-ball
did you try to go for t-ball or you just
didn't even try for sports i tried um
but the asthma and the weight it just
didn't asthma overweight great living
with your mom your dad has nothing to do
with you i mean these are
these are things that would [ __ ] up
almost anybody
for sure right yeah
man yeah but then i mean
you mentioned how like when you were 14
you were feeling insecure and and was
that just because you hadn't hit puberty
yet i mean were you still like a pretty
athletic normal kid well i guess i was
athletic but i remember we were like
played basketball it was indiana so
people played basketball and people
would do shirts and skins and i would if
i was a skin i'd say guys you know what
i don't feel well because i didn't want
to take my shirt off because i had no
hand on my arms and i remember mike
curry down the street was like harry and
the hendersons and he would be like
rosenbaum
you've got no hair under your arms
you're like 15.
what's up i'm like oh i'm a swimmer
i'm a swimmer yeah they we shave we
shave so you know it's the aerodynamics
through the water so that's what i do
fair i'd make up stories i was
embarrassed i was i mean i i remember
crying one day
because my dad was six foot five my
mother was relatively tall
and my mom was always you know she took
a lot of valium a lot of pills she was a
pill popper and yeah
my kind of person yeah exactly and dad
was always you know back in the day not
when i was
growing up but like smoked a lot of pot
when he was in his you know 18 and then
he he had me when he was 18 or 19 and my
mom was 23. wow but i remember
crying
i remember being in the kitchen and
going
if you do so many [ __ ] drugs
i wouldn't be so small what's wrong with
me you're tall you're tall
and i went and i just heard them
laughing as they left the room
and i was like god you're an idiot
but i mean i just it's uh
i don't know where i was going with that
how did jews make it to indiana uh dad
got a job transfer he got a job transfer
and uh it was it was weird i mean i
never really
felt the you know being a jew in indiana
that much i think my mom probably felt
it uh my dad they sensed it but i was
kind of ignorant to that i just sort of
like was in my own world my sister
experienced some people like one guy
throwing a quarter down the hallway and
saying go fetch it jew sure but you know
i didn't yeah terrible but i i didn't i
didn't
i wasn't privy to that i didn't feel
that in my life i had some
young cool friends and
um i did everything i could to get away
from my parents
i would just i want to stay out with my
friends as long as possible play
flashlight tag and capture uh fireflies
uh fireflies that they're called
fireflies and just stay out until i had
to come home you really didn't want to
be home you felt like that
totally and it wasn't
it was just the reality of like when you
have a mom who's in her 50s and she's
exhausted from working and slowly taking
a kid around all day like i remember on
the weekends if we did one thing and
we're in new york right so it's not like
you know there weren't kids in my
building and like i couldn't just go no
i mean around i remember around like 11
when i started middle school at sixth
grade i started taking the bus the the
crosstown bus alone
which you know how old 12 12. so that
was that was my freedom pass but i
remember if like my mom and i would do
one thing on a saturday like go to the
mall for two hours and eat at the food
court like that was it like when we got
home at two we were shut down for the
night and i was like [ __ ] like yeah now
it's me and the tv
to
10. she got so lonely what did she was
she uh the type of mother because i know
she's a jewish mother but would she
talk about your weight you have to lose
weight you have to or would she just
feed you and you need to eat which way
did it go well she had always she has
always struggled with food and weight
we're just we come from a family of big
people
so i knew that i saw firsthand that i
was like oh food is an issue for the
pecs like it's this like menacing force
so at like five six seven years old i
would like be sitting playing game boy
at weight watchers meetings that she was
at just over to the side or overeaters
and honestly you were just there for her
yeah because she had no one to leave me
with
wow but it's certainly informed food was
the ultimate focus and food was great or
terrible it was
brisket for holidays or popcorn at the
movies or let's order chinese or it was
you know we have to only keep cold cuts
in the fridge because otherwise mom will
binge and we have to make sure there's
no like fruit by the foot or dunkaroos
around here because josh will lose his
[ __ ] and blackout
i'll find him on the floor drooling
right yeah oh my god did you get made
fun of oh yeah viciously really in
school at a young age you remember being
called what yeah i remember at the gcc
the first time when i was eight years
old and a kid called me a fat [ __ ] and i
was like bad [ __ ] how old is he i was
like really at our community center like
we're supposed to band together guys
were you humiliated oh it was the i'll
tell you it was the first thing because
obviously i was hyped to the fact of
like oh i'm bigger than my fellows like
i you have a really good attitude i mean
you're like you have this this sort of
feeling i don't know you're so ahead of
your time that i would be just like a
mess and you're like well you know what
this is why this is happy you have
always these thoughts like well i have a
reason for this there's a reason for
this it feels like there's a light bulb
that went you're just a smarter kid than
i was i don't know i i think i i maybe
it's where i portray it now because then
it was
i remember when he said that it was like
the first
time it wounded and i was like oh like
being this way is gonna be challenging
yeah this is gonna and i think i very
soon after i made a decision that like
as an overweight person true or not this
was what i thought
you walk into a room at a debt like at a
disadvantage people make a snap judgment
about you that you're you know slothful
you lack control
and that it it was incumbent on me to
win them over and i think that's what
inspired comedy and whatnot because i
was like how do i
even i just i don't even want to be
thought of as great i just want to be on
an even playing field as everyone else
so you thought if you were doing
stand-up comedy and you can kind of show
them up and kind of say hey look i'm not
that guy i'm funny i've got i'm creative
i have talent i have all these things so
don't look at me as the fat guy look at
me as a creative funny yeah you know and
what would you make like in your stand
up would you use your weight as part of
the
joke you know yeah like i had you know
and
i'm sure they probably had it in indiana
entenmann's um it was like store brands
and pastries yes yes i don't know if
it's big on the west coast but you know
it's like store brand danish and donuts
and huge on the east coast and one of my
jokes when i was like 10 years old was i
at school i majored in entomology the
study of entemens
[Laughter]
coming out of a little fat kid's mouth
they were like oh this is genius this is
great so i i surely was like i'll make
fun of myself first
so you don't have the chance and in
doing so hopefully when you over wow and
this is something you were telling your
mom at a young age i wanna i wanna do
stand up
yeah i mean she was my mom is like the
ultimate sort of vaudevillian i mean
she's she's 77 right so
her contemporaries were mel brooks and
carl reiner and the true greats of
comedy but she was like the self-made
businesswoman
um a female in the workforce in the 70s
and 80s who like had to deal with a lot
of male [ __ ] and dealing with like
weight and just all this stuff all these
challenges so i would watch her take
over rooms like she was she was very
confident always ready with a joke oh
it's just like a natural she was
overweight yes very overweight always
like you talked about with weight
watchers she was very heavy she would
vacillate sometimes she would be totally
like at a normal weight and it was great
and then she could put on a good amount
of weight quickly so it just was it
yo-yo throughout my whole life did she
date did she date did you see other men
that came into the picture or no never
what oh she's giving me that movie line
like when i you know when you were born
like that ended for me
she never dated after you
not so you don't think your mom since
she had you at 43 has had sex in
30-something years i hope not
i don't want to think about it
i don't know i mean i think probably but
it's like it was probably
she was in such survival mode my whole
life and i was just hurt her utter focus
that if she did i'm hoping it was just a
quick fling and i hope they were nice to
her
i hope they used a rubber yeah exactly i
don't mean another one of me out there
like well how did it all start like you
started doing comedy your mom notices
he's got something he's got a spark he's
funny yeah and then what you you went to
an agent you had how'd you get an agent
i so i was reading did you ever when you
were starting out as an actor did you
read backstage magazine of course new
york yeah yeah i was not i was eight or
nine years old and this was before stand
up and i find this guy in the classified
sid gold at gold star entertainment sid
gold still around reps jennifer lawrence
no i'm kidding no no no he doesn't
yeah
jennifer leibowitz though
well that's who jennifer lawrence was
sure exactly
um
but yeah so he i go in and and i meet
him and and the ads like i represent
people of all ages and
and he's a sweet guy and he says listen
i can get you placed that maybe caroline
stand up new york i can get you a little
stage time so if you can put together an
act
five minutes of comedy i will get you
stage two how do you and uh how old are
you
eight or nine yeah but how do you get
into a comedy club isn't it like alcohol
and things like that what do they want a
kid who's eight or nine up there so i
started at afternoon shows so try doing
stand up at two yeah nobody there
terrible terrible so i do those but it
was like a shtick i just had this vision
of you i just said so anyway uh
entenmann's and uh okay nobody has some
chicken tenders yeah exactly the thing
about pokemon is like you know i can't
do any crowd work because no one has has
my references um
but yeah and then as i got better at it
and i there was like oh there's like
this
kid comedian who's got this shtick like
maybe we can we can sandwich them in
between real comedians at 11 o'clock at
night they would have to sneak me in so
they wouldn't lose their liquor license
wow yeah like through the back door
anybody famous that you'd go after that
you could recall
or that was up that night i'm trying to
no i mean i remember i was on a tv show
with with a young before half baked
chapelle really and i was like i'm a
comedian too he's like okay what was
that all
it was the tv show was called fox after
breakfast fox after breakfast tom
bergeron really and chappelle was on
that yeah and how old were you i was 11.
i'll show you the picture it's great i
have to see it and it and chappelle was
there chappelle couldn't have been older
than 24. do you remember him being very
funny were you like this guy's really
funny yeah i mean i think at that time i
was like oh this guy will get to my
level eventually
you were cocky
yeah i mean i was just like the beauty
of that age where as soon as you're good
at something and especially like it
wasn't being good at athletics at that
age where you're probably good amongst a
lot of good kids i was such an outlier
like a good comedian who had a you know
a good 11 year old comedian was so rare
so i certainly felt like oh i've got
this little
superpower this little thing and your
mom saw it too did she see it as a as a
like you know you know those moms yeah
they're like oh this is a vehicle this
he could make some money for me and for
him and this could be great for the both
of us and or was she just like do what
you want to do she always do what you
want to do or was she like do this
she was pretty she was pretty incredible
about it i have to be honest like
i just you know we we were so up and
down financially and you shared a room
in your apartment you lived in you had a
one bedroom and that you shared with
your mother
yeah so like we we literally went from
sharing a studio where we would switch
off on like a murphy bed and the couch
and then we got a one bedroom and
basically the living room turned into
her room and i had the bedroom and then
we lived in a different one bedroom and
we switched that she's like enough
already like i i require a bedroom i was
like it's fine i'll be i'll be fine here
near the terrace
and then
yeah and then i remember i was 12 years
old and i was starting to like make you
know i was just starting to i did the
conan o'brien show and rosie o'donnell
and i'm like oh maybe this could work
out for me and we went broke again
and i talk about in the book like the
book i don't know when the veil of
adolescence falls and all of a sudden
you're like
oh like life is unjust like life is
unfair
this sucks you started to feel that yeah
it was a really rough summer of like
1998 and i just was like i need to do
something about this not pushed or
prompted by my mom but more so like i
don't want to be this powerless
and at the whim of my mom's career
because it's too up and down she's doing
her best but
i just don't want to feel this way
anymore and i think i saw that that was
an inflection point where i really
double down on
on acting really and stand up yeah and
so what was the first thing that you
remember going oh thank god
this is going to bring some money on the
you know
back home well i had a jew i had you
know jewish grandparents and and um
aunts and uncles who are all like this
is cute but you know this is a hobby
right this is no way to live what you're
doing really they thought that about
acting in general yeah they were like
you'll do this until you go to law
school right and i was like
no probably not who's paying
exactly
and i remember that summer and it was
really tough and my mom looked at me and
you know i was going to go from my
elementary school to middle school in my
district but we didn't have a district
anymore because we had to move in the
middle of the night
and she was like you know there's a
performing arts high school
on the west side near times square you
should audition for that like i think
you would i think you'd you'd love it
and
i went there
ten days later i'm would you have to do
give a monologue no i did i did five
minutes of stand up
for the vice principal shout out miss
bruno miss bruno you know she had the
eye she had the eye of the tiger
of the talent of the the baby talent
yeah the baby talent but i walk into
that school and all of a sudden
i'm surrounded by these kids who are on
broadway and they're on tv shows and
they're making grown-up money i was like
that girl has a car i was like
like she's 16 and she has a car in new
york that's in pot no one has a car in
new york so you didn't feel like you fit
in really did you well what i felt was
like oh maybe my
aunts and uncles and grandparents are
wrong maybe you can do this and make
grown-up money
so it was a bit like
it basically at every turn whether it
was that moment or when i got my first
tv show it was a level up it was like oh
i'm gonna really have to dedicate myself
to this now if i want to operate it
these kids level and you were
intimidated or you were just like i i'm
not intimidated i'm ready to [ __ ] get
there oh yeah i did i think i did more
extracurriculars that year because like
i'm in this fun house for weird musical
theater kids so you got in you got into
the performing arts school oh my god i'm
in and i'm doing i was like in choir in
dance in vocal in in drama classes
everything oh i just was like from home
you were always at school the best i was
the after school kid like
before this my mom would drop me off at
the ymca and
um or she'd drop me off at school then
we'd go to the ymca six so i was out of
the house from eight to six every day
and you loved it i was heaven i was like
who another round to kick the can anyone
brothers sisters and how old are you 9
10 oh yeah that was yeah and it worked
for her she had to work you know i mean
i have a kiddo now who's three
and like i have a wife and i've got a
lot of support and i'm still like ah
that's not enough time in the day right
yeah oh my god it's a lot so
so you're going to this performing arts
school you've got this agent sid gold
god bless him i'd moved on sorry dawn
already from sid what can i say i mean
you were only with sit for a for a year
maybe
maybe
and you moved on was he very upset i
think he's my a buddy of mine the other
day was like i i was wrapped by sid gold
too he got me like a tv show i was like
i should have stuck her out everybody
[ __ ] leaves sid gold what is that and
he's still going these people leave him
they come into his life he helps them
and then they just let go of them who do
you know they remember the name of your
first agent
there was one um arthur
arthur something but i remember
i told him that i'm gonna go with this
other agency oh
and i remember i called him and i said
hey what was his [ __ ] name
and i just remember him going hey first
he goes hello
i go hey it's michael where's my goes
michael how you doing
and i'm like good listen i just wanted
to talk to you um
you know i there's this uh you know this
other agent that's pursuing me and
they've got this commercial department
goes go for it [ __ ] off
that was it
how healthy just was like [ __ ] you was
he you know a one-man shop like he was
kind of a one-man shop he was like [ __ ]
you go do whatever you want he was so
insulted that i would consider another
agent of course it wasn't maybe as blunt
but it was pretty like hang up the phone
and i remember going
wow
yeah i guess
uh that wasn't right for me
i wonder if sid gold got pissed off when
you left and was like [ __ ] you josh
[ __ ] i was getting forty dollars a night
at caroline so i think he was getting a
percentage of that four bucks he was
really getting you would send him money
i don't know
i don't want your four bucks kid
i want that uh was it an acura what did
you get the car the free car right now
later on mdx the the full-size sedan
really suv jesus is so lucky i mean and
technology package nice nav
nice navigating system
inside of you is brought to you by
patreon
that's right patreon
listen guys
patreon helps the podcast survive it's
people over there my patrons who give
back to the podcast a little bit more
and there's so many friendships that
have spawned from this and relationships
people on patreon that support the
podcast
and i really appreciate it but it's
built in incredible community uh if you
want to get early access to episode
content
check out the patreon if you want to
interact with fans of the show check out
the patreon if you want to get exclusive
access to have your questions asked
during the show uh check out the patreon
i mean ryan heck if you just love what
we do and you want to keep this train
rolling check out that patreon uh it
doesn't take much to get involved and
i'm there all the time i'm chatting with
folks and putting together live hangouts
i literally could not do this like i
said without my patrons so to get more
involved in the community today head
over to patreon.com inside you that's
p-a-t-r-e-o-n patreon.com inside of you
and i will message you right after you
join and i am excited to see your name
uh patreon.com inside of you and i will
see you there soon
so you're a mother at this point and
you're taking all these classes and
extracurricular she's seeing something
she's like seeing this love this passion
for it yeah she knew did she you know
then that you know you're going
somewhere
you know when i eventually a year later
got offered this tv show in california
and basically i had to leave my whole
life to go do that what was that it was
called the amanda show with amanda bynes
amanda how is she to work she's the
greatest was she really the greatest
again much like going to this performing
arts high school i show up and it's a
sketch comedy show
and she's she's like the carol burnett
and
i and of course they ice me right away
which i don't blame them for but i had
been sort of put i had been highly
suggested that i get this job from the
president of nickelodeon who had met me
a year before and was like you got
something you're funny
and
as you know producers love being told
what to do right and they were like okay
and they took me but they didn't know so
i was relegated to waiter number three
in sketchup oh boy
but instead of being resentful i was
like embraced it yeah and i just watched
her because i'm like we're six months
apart in age but you are like decades
ahead of me in ability and i just sort
of studied her instead of being pissed i
was on the bench
did she like you
i think or did she not really was aware
of you she wasn't aware of you as much
as like i don't well you were the third
waiter this the server yeah i remember
yeah you had you have something yeah you
like the snack table
you still like the snack table at that
point oh that's when i really started
doing damage i'm like this is free
this is this is good we got free food
you know as much food as you want though
and no one ever complained about your
weight like any producers or directors
or they just embrace it like yeah let
him be the overweight kid oh they loved
it i mean i was especially in the early
2000s like i was
fulfilling a niche like a thing
especially in like y.a or kids tv there
was always the fat friend or the fat
bully
and like
that was a big part that was sort of my
inspiration or motivation to lose weight
was like if i really want to act i'm
being relegated and stereotyped into
these like two parts and it doesn't seem
like they're writing parts for people
like me that's anything more than this
right but yeah i mean it's obviously so
much better now and i don't mean i think
some people might read my book and think
i speak hyperbolically about myself or
or i'm taking the piss out of myself too
much but
it was it was truly a different world
right
for a guy who looked like me at that
time
right and this kind of led you into when
you did drake and josh it was sort of
the same thing well yeah drake was so
amanda was on all that which was like
snl for kids right she got amanda show
drake and i were on amanda show and we
got our own show a year later they liked
you guys that much that you just
blossomed on the show yeah you got your
own show
yeah they called the guy who created all
that and amanda showed this guy dan
schneider and they were like do you have
another like
buddy comedy idea because he had made
keenan and cal
and he said nope
they were like great well if you have an
idea let us know
and
drake and i are doing a scene towards
the last episode of the season
and this guy steve milaro who's now you
know huge writer and and producer for
chuck laurie he goes over to dan and
goes um don't they want you to write a
buddy comedy and he said yeah he's like
it's those two idiots like those really
he's like that's your b those are your
buddies
and six months later we were on the set
of drake and josh were you were you
shocked that you're getting your own
show seemed like that's how it worked
like oh this is how hollywood works like
you do good on one show and then you get
your own show at least for kids tv and
your mom is in la with you because you
moved with her from new york to l.a yeah
she's there to support you we've got a
two-bedroom apartment at the avalon i'm
talking amenities like a racquetball
court
um what a treat carpet
carpet nice carpet a fridge with the ice
dispenser
like we could not we were literally
happy we could not believe
how good our life was and how close were
you with drake at that point very very
tight very good friends
no we never
we i think what was always
we were naturally just kind of like we
had a brotherly type thing where it was
either we were close or or we were
really not but
what we could appreciate about each
other i think was like
there's some magic here like something
works between us i remember
not to like compare to true geniuses but
don rickles has this great quote about
him and um
um
oh my god i'm bored kilmer no his
[Laughter]
his partner bob newhart oh new horror of
course and he always said here i was
this jew from queens
and
is that is it ice cream no
it's i never turn it off it's the cuckoo
clock cute yeah so if you hear the
cuckoo clock it means it's a really good
episode love it everyone it's noon no is
it
it's uh it's so it's almost noon perfect
yeah oh you have a cuckoo clock for like
11 50. yeah
so it's off it's it's off it's off i i
it really is it doesn't work right it's
just it goes off whenever it wants to
that's even more yeah but i need to turn
it off
but go ahead new heart so and uh rickles
has this great quote about him in
newhart where he's like here i was just
like you know jewish kid from queens and
he was this you know catholic guy from
the midwest came from totally different
backgrounds but something about us
together worked
and like drake's a you know some kind of
christian from orange county and i'm
this chubby jew kid from new york but
like somehow when we got together it
worked it worked it worked but you net
didn't necessarily get along or liked
each other or hung out it just worked it
just worked but did you go home and say
mom i just really don't like drake
somebody's just a real [ __ ] he's so
mean
i don't know no sometimes i mean and i'm
sure he said the
some version of that knowing josh peck
can't stand them oh he's eating all the
snacks right it's like enough already
i'm self-control
troll
i'm trying
yeah but it was yeah and it you know we
made people i think think we did a lot
more of it but we only made 60 episodes
over like five years what were they
paying you then oh
i want to know so far i'm i'm curious
it's not much is it
so i think at the height of it we made
10 000 an episode or at the height 15 i
i i
when it became kind of
i guess it lasted 60 episodes how many
seasons is that
four four seasons so by the fourth
season you're making 10 15 grand an
episode i think like the median i say in
the book is like when all is said and
done i think we it averages to about 15
000 an episode
and i i only because it's gross to talk
about money except for i think the
misconception is like if you are on a
show yeah that's what i want to talk
about because i think people say you're
making hundreds of thousands of dollars
and millions of dollars you're on a show
you've made it and that kind of money as
much as it sounds in the 15 000 an
episode does sound like a lot of money
to most people but you take the taxes
you're in a tax bracket you take all the
agents and the managers and the
commissions and you're left with about
six and you're living yeah you're just
living you have to live you have to pay
for your apartment so at the end of the
year like 4 000.
yeah that money goes by quickly that's
why you think how did this guy get broke
right he was on the show for four years
because he really wasn't making that
much in la to live in l.a is is very
expensive
yeah so i always i'm always curious i'm
always curious like how much did they
make on like a kids show like that you
know but and no residuals
no residuals i love telling people that
i don't know that's [ __ ] i think i'm
like one of those weirdos who likes to
tell people like someone's passed away
like you know fran passed john died yeah
i didn't ask you that yeah i know i know
but you should know yeah and fran they
died together i love telling people
about no residuals and kids tv because
they all have your reaction they're like
how how how yeah people always think
it's like oh hulu just bought smallville
you must be making millions i don't
think i've gotten one check really not
nothing streaming they haven't figured
streaming out yet i don't i don't think
so dude streaming is so and i i gotta
give respect to like netflix and every
gigantic streamer it's the most
beautifully gangster move of like a
corporation we don't understand it
we don't know what to pay you we don't
know this is just
yeah and we did you and we're not going
to tell you whether you're doing good or
not because that gives you leverage
what do you get into in your book
briefly about uh drake and josh do you
get into the dark stuff at all what do
you mean was there any dark stuff while
you're filming that was there anything
that you remember that just you know uh
you saw some things that you as a kid
you probably shouldn't
be privy to i mean i
what i really talk about uh drake and i
specifically and it's really just like
the way in which people marry themselves
to you
when they fall in love like the people
fall in love with the first image they
have of you and it really sets the tone
for the way they're going to think about
you forever like steve carrell's the man
one of our greatest actors most people
will think of him as michael scott
forever for better or for worse because
that show is so beloved right
and so with drake and i like i said what
meant the most to me was what this show
meant to other people and because it was
in reruns for free forever
yeah like
i'll still at 35 having not shot an
episode of that for almost 20 years have
new kids and families come up to me and
talk about how much they love it and
it's a testament to the show that it
sort of had that lasting
power but
so no one to me had to ever know that
drake and i weren't exactly close right
you don't talk to him anymore at all i
don't but i got married a few years ago
and i didn't invite him because
we're not close
and he didn't like that no and he took
to the internet
and
basically like i think he wrote an
innocuous shitty tweet
that then caught fire and he leaned in
completely when he saw how outraged
people were because they're like no you
guys were just sharing a room last week
like that was 11 years ago
jesus and i was like so they got down on
you oh crushing for a really long time
since then people i think have actually
you know
that's hurtful
it's like i didn't invite you because we
never were really friends and people
don't know that and it's been 12 years
we don't talk my wife's irish got big
family yeah
i have friends i see once a month and i
didn't invite them of course but you
know that and i know that
but like you know
the twitter mob did not understand that
yeah
and mostly i was just outraged because i
was like my wife's a private person
she's not an actor and she's supposed to
be in the afterglow of like this very
special event and she's being [ __ ] on by
12 year olds who are like calling her
yoko
oh
she broke up yeah crazy crazy did you
ever tweet out and say [ __ ] you i didn't
because i i had some really great
counsel in that moment moments where i
was like ripping my hair out where i'm
like why am i the most famous i've ever
been for the worst thing ever right in
this moment like tmz never gave a [ __ ]
about me but somehow they want to talk
to me right now
and my friends were like well what would
you say and i
much like i just said i'm like i tell
the truth they're like so you're the
bearer of bad news
like you're gonna be telling the world
that you guys were never close
they're like you can't you won't win
you're right wow i never thought about
that
yeah he was right wasn't he yeah they
were like just shut up and they're like
reasonable p reasonable people will know
it and even people who are outraged now
over time will be like uh
actually that kind of scene
yeah i didn't i didn't think about that
but wow it's like people's perception of
like you know when i was on a show they
they they don't want to know that we
were actually arch enemies
you know that really you know they don't
want they don't want to know that they
want to think that we you know like
maybe we were i don't know i don't know
what people think but i think they like
that we're friends we are friends we
become stronger friends the opposite of
you guys really yeah we've become
stronger friends as the years go on um
we're doing a couple projects together
and that's awesome but you know but
that's not for everybody there's a lot
of people i've worked with that i i
wouldn't invite to my [ __ ] wedding
would you say it's more i mean you've
worked so much and done so many cool
things of all different
types and huge things and indie stuff
like shitty things same here we've all
done shitty things um but nice house
right sometimes the shitty things it's
great for the house very grateful i'm
doing something cool next month hey
nothing beautiful look at these
beautiful shore mics that we're using
gorgeous yeah they're great joe rogan
approved yeah exactly
um but would you say like i find like
that's the rare occurrence like i've
maybe collected in 20 years two or three
people
from projects from like i love them
they're a big part of my life yes
everyone else nice
that's the same with me yes there's a
couple people that i'll talk to here and
there that i like talking to but you
know i don't talk to them constantly
right and it's nice to catch up like for
instance kristen crook who's uh lana
lang on smallville sure she and i were
friends i consider her a friend but how
often do i see her maybe at a convention
signing an autograph or you know i asked
her to do my podcast and she's very
sweet and she'll you know uh she'll do
it
she asked me to do something i would do
it if she needed a favor i would do it
but we don't see each other all the time
but we're you know i consider her my
friend yes but um
you know there comes most the people
that you work with are just like whether
you like them or you don't like them
it's just it's work it's work and you
work with them enough and you really
there's nothing else or you don't have
anything in common or there's just you
have different lives it's camp it's
camera people don't people don't
understand that but yeah when did you uh
decide and why did you decide to lose
all the weight and this is again this is
in the book yes this is all in the book
yes happy people are annoying happy
people are annoying what you guys i i
can't i can't wait to read it now i'm so
glad that we got to talk because
i find this really interesting this
story is something that a lot of people
don't know about this world and growing
up with a single mom and not having the
father and you know
finding a spark finding something you
like with stand up and then you know it
takes you out to la and you somehow get
your own show after being the the third
waiter on the left on the amanda bind
show and it's just this build up in the
story that i think would make a great
movie if you condensed it so i urge you
guys to check that out but um thank you
so when when did that time come were you
like did someone tell you you need to
lose weight did you think like i want to
lose weight i want to look different
what was it
i think there you know i was 17 years
old and on yet another road trip with my
mom and
i
there was it was sort of this perfect
storm which was i'd been incredibly
insecure and in many ways what i find my
my
saving grace now when people are like oh
you're pretty normal for an actor at 35
and i'm like well at the moments in
where my ego could have completely got
out of control
i was 100 pounds overweight
so
constantly i was like don't get too
hyped about yourself look at you
and so
every time i could have gone to a party
or a club or something cliche i just was
like i'll just stay home and alphabetize
my dvd it's like that's sad yeah it's
sad it really is it's a shame it was
i i it is and
i i just knew what there was this moment
at 17 where i was like i miss some stuff
like some pivotal things i can already
tell and you've also probably saved
yourself in a lot of ways because you
could have gotten to some deep trouble
you know you start going out with all
these kids and partying and you see what
happens no offense but like you see what
happens with some of the people you've
worked with and
[ __ ] happens
and so maybe not being around that
saved you in many ways yeah i mean that
would come for me a year and a half
later but i right but i
uh but what was a real turning point was
when i was 16 i did a movie called mean
creek right and it won sundance and i
was playing uh uh
overweight bully but it was the first
time that i was playing a real person
and what you come to learn in the movie
is that he was this beautifully
tragic character who
was deeply insecure and and had learning
disabilities and really just desperately
wanted friends and and it's this
beautiful sort of executed movie
and the response was unreal and all of a
sudden i'm truly
you know people would always sort of
there was always always a caveat to if
someone gave you a compliment about
drake and josh or something because
they'd say oh but that's just you i mean
it's literally your name right but this
was like oh you're
you're a character you're doing
something or something right so i was
like
and judd apatow wasn't around then like
guys who were giving non-traditional
leading men great parts so i'm like i
can't wait another 10 years for this
like another part like this isn't coming
around for a really long time and if i
want to be able to really be the kind of
actor i want to be i need to be able to
transform and i can't do that
at this size you're 17 years old and
this is what you've come up with you've
all these things have gone through your
mind yeah and you realize
i've got to make some changes in my life
yeah i want to do this i want to be
seriously taken i want and and i i want
to do other work
and i
i want to stay in this business yeah and
so you made the decision
on your own
to lose all this weight
i was so sick and tired i i remember
distinctly saying if i can be a movie
star at 300 pounds or
normal and go do a 9-5 job i'd rather be
at a healthy weight and do that yeah and
give it all up
so that was like and i always say you
know everybody wants a hack or a secret
especially when it comes to losing
weight because i feel like no matter who
you are you're contending
some in some way with food and
i say you know
what i can tell you is if you're truly
sick and tired it's a great place to
start because i never learned anything
on a good day like pain is the great
motivator of my life unfortunately you
got to get pretty low to finally be like
i can't take this anymore
how hard was it to lose all that weight
i mean i think i was like the first 10
year old on atkins so
i had tried for years right and i would
just
you know i'd lose five pounds in two
days and then put it right back on
because like it was not sustainable
right so those i remember i was i went
back home to new york for the summer for
two months
and i just walked the city because it
was like the only thing that didn't hurt
and i would eat better and if i screwed
up and had mr softy one day cause it's a
summer in new york i wouldn't let it
ruin the whole week i would just say
just live to fight another day tomorrow
and suddenly and i would plateau but i
mean and and i'm vain so
you go from 300 pounds to 260 in a
summer two months people start really
going like wow and then you know you
drop the next 40 and the next 40 and
suddenly they're like who knew
like there was like was it exciting oh
yeah did you like the transformation
was it all just like
as hard as it was did it feel like this
is working this is people are seeing me
differently
oh yeah i do i remember i went to the i
would go to the mall once i got under
200 pounds i would go to the mall and go
to all the stores i dreamed of wearing
their clothes like express
express has men's clothing yeah i don't
know that at a great rate reasonable
shout out to express i think i knew that
i've seen the united colors of benadon
another good one
so i would go to mervin's and
bloomington coat factory no but again
i'm seeing this in the movie i'm seeing
the scene where you go to all these
stores and look in there and you're just
happy and you're like you know and your
friend comes up to you hey i'm getting
some ice cream on somebody's like no
i'll have a diet coke
or something and you know it's just like
it's so visual but it's so
it is it's got to be an exciting time in
your life that you're like you're like
hey i'm disciplined yeah i'm doing this
and it's working
yeah i thought that i had just made it
like right before the buzzer like you
did it like you're gonna have the chance
at living
life as a thin person and you because
that was what i've always resisted being
defined by by
like that's what i hate you know i i
don't hate it it is what it is now but
like i hated being the kid actor the
child actor because i knew that that
triggered in people's brains like for
every zendaya or or or jodie foster
there were a thousand other kids that
just you know completely nose-dived in
front of the public and so i'm like i
don't want to be in that class i just
want to be an actor i don't want to be
the fat funny guy i just want to be an
actor amongst actors right um but yeah
that was
that was huge when i lost the weight it
was it was a game changer but
unfortunately i was the same head in a
new body
and
pretty quickly i got to my goal weight
and then became viciously addicted to
drugs and alcohol
took over the next four years of my life
and how did your mom respond to that was
she heartbroken she was like you always
overdo it
she so she knew you were doing these
drugs oh yeah and she didn't she wasn't
angry or upset oh yeah she was
heartbroken terrified she was yeah every
day for four years i don't think she
slept what kind of drugs did you do i
did them all cocaine oh yeah heroin
i know okay right well that's good
because that could have been the end of
it if you got went there i did you know
i mostly it was a lot of you know
cocaine and and pills and pretty much
whatever you had
uh right when i turned 18. 18. so you
finally get this new lust for life
you're thinner you you want to be this
actor you're excited you love the way
people are looking at you differently
and you [ __ ] throw it into the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you just throw the whole thing down the
drain by doing all these drugs and [ __ ]
you're just getting you're hanging out
with the wrong crowd
yeah well those kids like the ones who
are going to the clubs i was like oh
take me i've been you know my dvds are
alphabet you're getting laid at this
time no i mean i wound up doing cocaine
for the first time because of a girl
because she was the first girl who had
ever shown me any attention
and i remember her pulling it out and
i'm at this what
not it oh oh okay okay
but maybe you know
i don't know we never got that far i
never got that i'll be honest
[Laughter]
geez
the book gets really weird around page
120 i'm sure it does tactic
um but no i was at this party and like i
think i'd smoke pot but that was the
extent of it and i just remember her you
know
doing cocaine with like her girlfriends
and i'm seeing it there i'm like oh this
is like pulp fiction
it's like the movies like this is a
movie stars do man totally you kind of
feel that you're like oh i'm in
hollywood and i'm doing drugs and this
is what i need to be doing not even that
far it was this is what kids do like
this is what typical
i've been working towards typical my
whole life and my whole adolescence was
besieged by you have to
mine your p's and q's don't say anything
out of turn do you want another take
boss like i'm not those other child
actors like i know my lines and i'm on
my mark like
like louder faster like am i okay will
this casting director give me a part i
just want you to think i'm okay i was in
this crazy people-pleasing
you know storm my whole life and
suddenly i'm like now looking like a
normal kid and a normal teen
and i'm like oh
they do drugs and that's normal and they
go to house parties and they go to clubs
and they show up late to places and
they're unreliable and that's normal and
i i died to be normal and i remember the
first when i fir finally said yes
i had no consensus conception that this
drug would make me feel any different
that it was extreme
all i thought was a i hope she's
watching
and oh good i'm normal
isn't that f isn't that [ __ ]
it is [ __ ] to think that that's
normal like hey i need to be doing this
because this is what kids do right this
is what everybody's doing yeah it's it's
it's crazy it's crazy i'm on party of
five right now like um right i'm all
those 90s movies what was the you know
i'm almost done here because i could
talk i could talk to you for a long time
no no worries but this is uh what was
the
did you make the conscious effort to
sort of stop doing the drugs did you was
there a low point where you hit so low
that you're like what am i doing oh yeah
what was that moment do you remember the
moment or moments it was a culmination
and especially like in recovery you hear
so many like
you know
um what's it called like
white light you know
utter moments of defeat that are so
cinematic you're like i wish that was me
but it for me it was sort of this i was
ruining my relationships i was quickly
becoming just like unreliable and
it was just getting around quickly like
pex going through something i wouldn't i
wouldn't consider him
um right ruin relationships with like
people that really could have changed my
life um
some run it some running away from the
police
really yeah i had the proclivity for
calling the police on myself because i
thought there was some like incentive
for being the first to notify them
there is it there's not they're still
pissed yeah they're still like well we
got to do our job but thanks for giving
thanks for calling us you [ __ ] idiot
who is this kid now i'm like wow beverly
hills pd like you you have quick
response
nice response time quick response um and
then
and i just broke my mom's heart on a
daily basis which is corny but true but
i i talk about this in the book like
as i said before all i wanted to be was
a real actor not a kid actor not the
funny fat guy and i get this part in
this movie called the wackness
which was about 1994 hip-hop in new york
and i was 20 years old and i'm acting
against sir ben kingsley my favorite
actor
wow and i was like and i knew i was i
was like i know nine times out of ten
i'm like give it to jonah hill
like he'll do a better job or like are
you sure miles teller is not available
because i'm pretty sure he'd crush this
wow but this story this guy was like a a
new york hip-hop kid a jewish kid from
new york who loves hip-hop i know how to
do this
so the movie goes to sundance and i'm
literally and i dreamed of this when i
was doing mean creek i dreamed i'm like
one day i'm going to be back here as a
star of a movie and i'm going to look
the way i want to look
and there i was i was 21
and we'd do this screening and [ __ ]
tarantino's there and i'm like this is
it i've been invited to the table i'm
eating like i am here
and i just remember the next morning i
my eyes start open
and i go
i'm getting out of here and i
i booked a flight and everyone's like
you nuts you have a well-received movie
sundance this doesn't happen like
and i i just as soon as i had finally
arrived at this finish line i dreamed of
i was like oh i'd never want to be part
of a club that would have me as a member
like this is the groucho marx quote like
it just doesn't it didn't compute and
what was really rough was i had this
realization which was
oh no you're bottomless
like you tried to fill this with food
then drugs and alcohol and now like
prestige
and none of it nothing's gonna fill the
void none of it and i got sober two
weeks later
two weeks later yeah well i had to make
sure i was right
i'm sure i could drink this thought away
wow and how do you feel now
oh man i'm so overpaid i'm here with you
yeah got a kid a wife from working you
know i've been able to keep my [ __ ]
together for a good good amount of time
i'm
i'm lucky did you ever think he could be
this happy
no oh no way i didn't think i just
didn't think that i would ever
you know a good life as a result of good
living like my life mimics that of like
a good man but i'm not a good man i mean
maybe but like at my heart like i want
to set fire to the city like deep down i
just want like i say this at the end of
the book
and the reason why i wrote wrote it at
35 instead of maybe 55 or maybe i'd have
some cooler stories was like i just want
to like i want to give you a perspective
of the halfway point
you know and
i just said like
despite the fact that i work now and and
my life is so great like when [ __ ] hits
a fan like i think about getting a bunch
of drugs and white castle hamburgers and
just seeing what happens
you know like that's always going to be
in my head to some extent
but i've done the right thing over and
over enough to where it's like working
out it doesn't hurt as bad
yeah yeah
and it even feels really good if you you
know you could always say you've you've
done it yeah i did that and where did
that get me the drugs where did all that
how did i feel
and how did i feel about eating stuffing
my face and eating and being overweight
how did that make me feel yeah and you
start to say what makes me feel good why
don't i do things that make me feel good
and i think we all do things that
we punish ourselves yeah i think that
has a lot to do with it i think i've
punished myself in the past with you
know maybe drinking too much or drugs or
you know or just
other things
and ultimately you have to
like we said in the beginning you have
to be good to yourself you have to be
like hey this is this is the life that
i've been given i'm lucky i'm here yes
what can i do to help other people what
can i do to be a better person a better
man a better and it's hard
to do that
yeah but i think that
it's when you start doing the right
things you feel so much better it's so
obvious did you have moments when you
really started hitting as an actor like
those moments of cliche them where you
were like oh
like do you look back now and give you
the shivers not only that but it's
almost like i remember those moments
where i feel like there's a camera on me
as i'm doing whatever i'm doing yeah
like this is what i'm like you said this
is what i'm supposed to be doing i'm
supposed to be doing drugs at this huge
a-lister's house
with other a-listers and i'm supposed to
be you know partying with you know the
producers on this movie and i'm supposed
to be you're not supposed to be doing
any of that right not supposed to be
doing you know it's it's just it's this
idea this idea that we have of what
hollywood is and how we could fit in and
you know
as long as i've been here and you know
i'm almost 50 it's just like uh
it means nothing someone said what was
it allen richton says once i got famous
or i became whatever i still realize
there's just there's still nothing here
that's not the answer of being famous
being rich
that's not the answer to our lives
yes it's meaning it's relationships it's
connections it's what you talk about in
your book right yes and um
you know hopefully being content like we
said you know being content going hey
you know i'm
i'm all right i'm good enough i don't
need this other [ __ ] so other people
like me more so that uh you know i feel
like i fit in
um
but i i you've been through it and
you've been through so much and i just i
i really appreciate your candor and your
just your
generosity for being so open about all
your [ __ ] well you know it's it is the
weird it's the virtuous side of this
thing and i i don't know
you know you and i are of a similar
generation when it comes to show
business where like i feel like we were
of the last class of people
where social media wasn't a thing and
where celebrity was still like
mysterious right like the people i
looked up to growing up they would have
a movie and go on every talk show and do
something like kind of buzzy and then
they'd go away for a year yeah and make
their next movie
and so i assumed and i think
mostly mostly because i wanted to erase
my origin story like i want to be like
can i just
burn the yearbooks and start over swear
everyone to secrecy right right and
they're like no [ __ ] like your your
your yearbooks are on reruns
[Laughter]
like solid that's amazing that's amazing
but when i embraced my origin story when
i was like willing to get vulnerable in
order to hopefully be of service to
someone else and be like i was there too
and and if you're struggling you know i
hope i can give you a little bit of a
reprieve from that and show you like
it's possible
that was when it's it's stopped having
power over me yeah that's amazing um
quickly we have [ __ ] talking with josh
peck these are really rapid fire i'm
only going to give you a couple because
we've been talking too much and you know
this is this is amazing and uh you know
i never like to do interviews longer
than an hour
uh well listen
or i am
you know how i feel about that so these
are rapid fire quick questions uh these
are for my patrons if you join
patreons.com
inside you these are people who support
the show in many ways and i love you
guys and these are for you what's your
tiers
what do you get if you like what what's
the highest tier do we get well you'll
have to look at it special incentives
packages for me every couple of months
you know you get like a box full of cool
[ __ ] i love it there's each other oh
yeah there's uh there's their stuff i'm
signing up all right sign up good all
right here we go really quick maddie
asks enjoying your character on how i
met your father and you and hillary have
great chemistry can you share any fond
memories you have working on the show oh
man hillary's just dreamy as hell we
actually made a movie together about 15
years ago when i was in my drug days and
it was this little indie that not a lot
of people have seen and then 15 years
later when we saw each other on set i
was like i don't know if she remembers
that i was in that
and then a couple episodes in i'm like
hey remember we made that movie together
and she was like
oh yeah
and i was like good she doesn't remember
because so hollywood i was not memorable
at that time that was not me i was like
in the shadows like grinding my teeth
chelsea see if you had the chance to
work with someone other than ben
kingsley because that was like a
lifetime change change of a lifetime
chance of a lifetime what am i trying to
say you [ __ ] with ben kingsley
is that the first time anyone's ever
said that sentence but she didn't she
didn't say that ben's king i threw that
in there okay yeah i see that if you had
the chance to work with someone you look
up to most in hollywood who would it be
oh man the rock obviously really
i just look up to him in general as a
human i'm like how are your instagram
captioned so long
how's his arms so big yeah i just want
to do a workout with him christ
uh ryan do you have anything i mean
you're the same generation as josh
no yeah how do you feel about her
generation
um
give me a little more
are is social media
screwing us up too much probably but
we're awesome i i think the corniest
thing is taking shot like it's become
trendy to take shots at like millennials
or zoomers i was doing a podcast the
other day and this woman said to me like
so you do social media and stuff like
what about these kids the demelios and
all these people on tick tock that are
making all this money like what did they
even do and i was like i don't i don't
want to go there i'm like because i
don't want to be that [ __ ] old dude
who doesn't get it right like i'm like
they obviously have something that has
has gotten them an insane audience
and i have respect for it even if i
don't quite get it because i'm they're
doing this for me they're doing their
thing they're making money they're doing
you don't have to watch it you don't
have to listen to it no right i i hear
you i could be the old bastard too i
could do the old bastard thing i think
we all can
um
somebody wrote a great meme for the
super bowl show which was you know dre
and all this like great 90s hip-hop and
people were like if you are hyped about
this show it's time for your colonoscopy
i was so hyped for that show i loved it
i thought it was the best because it was
a throwback it was my generation it felt
good it was the best ever um
happy people are annoying get the book
uh how i met your father was on hulu you
could watch that anything else coming up
um no i have this movie called 13 coming
out on netflix sometime this year
awesome and what's your handle uh at
schuap on instagram you're gonna follow
me i'll follow you hey really yeah let's
follow each other let's do it in front
of each other so you know i think we
should do that i'll do it right now
thanks for allowing me to be inside you
this was a joy dude thank you it really
was thanks man
man
drugs
drugs will [ __ ] you up man drugs [ __ ]
drugs will [ __ ] you up man [ __ ]
you know it's you either get through it
or it just crushes you and he got
through it there's only
two ways yeah you either get through it
or you don't yep right there's no kind
of i mean there's the in and out but uh
you know the up and downs sort of in
drugs added drugs but if you're in drugs
and attitudes you never really added
drugs
drugs are bad okay drugs are really
lousy i mean not all drugs i don't think
uh marijuana is necessarily a bad drug
no i think it could help a lot of people
i think it does it helps glaucoma yeah
it helps with uh cancer patients yeah it
helps with my sleeping great this whole
podcast could just be listing things
that marijuana does good for yes
absolutely thanks for listening again
thanks for following us at inside of
your pod on twitter at inciti podcast on
instagram and facebook please write our
view on
spotify
or apple
it means a lot it really helps the
podcast and uh i appreciate it even if
you don't know the guest
and you listen to it or if you're here
for josh pack maybe next week you'll
enjoy the podcast as well you might
learn something so don't just watch for
josh peck we hope you stay with us and
everybody out there who's a listener uh
tell your uncle tell your friends get
them to subscribe tell your uncles for
insight take it tell your uncle's
friends for god's sakes i don't know i
don't know what you want to do and also
uh again the inside of you online store
go there get great stuff um also
a big thanks to all my patrons again and
uh this is one of the perks for the top
patrons you can go to patreon.com inside
you and i get to read off their names
so i think we can get into that right
now sweet let's do it these are the top
patrons here we go
nancy d leah s
sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e brian
h nico p robert b jason
w kristen k amelia o allison l raj c
joshua d c j p jennifer n stacy l gen s
jamal f janelle b correct roger s
kimberly e mike e aldon soprano
99 more
ramirez santiago
uh chad w santiago m chad w leon p
janine r
maya b
that's correct
maddie s belinda n chris h dave h
spiderman chase sheila g brad d ray h i
didn't use my my glasses that are a
little stronger so it's hard in these
glasses to see
spider-man chase sheila g brad d ray h
congratulations ray i won't say why but
thank you tab of the t tom and liliana
um
hello l a hey michelle
okay correct talia m betsy d chad r chad
l rochelle marion mckay travel dan n big
scooby-dooby big stevie w sorry
yeah you're not boring stevie big steven
w
angel m rhiannon c corey k super sam
coleman g dev nixon michelle a jeremy c
cody r gavinator david c john b brandy
l d d yeah four yvore
uh camille s the c joey m willie f
christina e adelaide and omar j lena ann
eugene and eugene and what and leah oh
yeah
chris p corey patricia heather l
jake b getting to the bottom here but
really the top you guys are at the
bottom
james b bobbitt ed
a bowl
it's a bowl right a bowl f
yeah a bowl yeah yeah i hope so yeah i
mean he keeps you know i have no idea i
think it's i'm gonna say thanks abel f
and here's another one thanks ebola f
keep them both yeah keep them both
joshua b tony g sean r megan t mel s
orlando c annie john b caroline r darren
b
and rob e
we uh we love you we appreciate you
and uh thanks for listening to the
podcast stay with us every week please
um i hope you enjoy it be very good to
yourselves it's very important to be
good good to yourselves give yourself a
break
uh ryan from myself we're here in the
hollywood
california yeah yeah i'm michael rosen
i'm ryan taylor and a little wave to the
camera good night we love you guys thank
you for thank you again for joining us
and uh we'll see you next week
[Music]